I was born and raised in Torrance.
Yeah, my whole family's from Torrance.
So it's the kind of a hometown feel and I
knew Torrance needed something like this.
I was a sociology major but I got
into the entrepreneurship minor at Anderson.
The entire program really
helped me develop something
that I wanted to build and make my own.
A lot of people have never seen the
concept of rolled ice cream.
Being able to watch your ice cream being made right
in front of you.
It's really fun and they're excited so it makes me happy.
UCLA has been a huge influence on me
and the fellow Bruins that come in here
is absolutely amazing and the love they
share for it.
UCLA has played a huge part in creating
such an amazing shop and environment.